foreign
[Music]
today I'm going to talk about my latest
project the dashboard Builder or how to
build shiny apps without writing code
and now quick disclaimer this is not the
UI Builder so yesterday at the keynote
it was a bit of an emotional roller
coaster for me because I saw all you
guys are doing in UI Builder I'm doing a
dashboard Builder okay
I'm just gonna see myself out okay
nothing to do here but I think it's
still a bit different
so if I'm not from our studio then who
am I well I'm Peter I just finished my
masters in data engineering and
analytics from the Technical University
in Munich
and in my free time I like to play chess
and do data visualizations especially
shiny dashboards now when I talk to
people and tell them about my hobbies
well most call me a nerd but there are
also a few people who say oh
visualizations dashboards I would like
to create more dashboards but
I don't know how
it's I can't write our code it's too
complex
and then there are some people who say I
could do it I know how to do it but I
have so many great ideas I just don't
have enough time
and I think these are all valid reasons
but I'm here I want to tell you to
create more dashboards so more
dashboards like this one I created about
my recent chess games
is this the most sophisticated the most
beautiful dashboard you've ever seen
probably not I hope not if it is go
check out the shiny gallery go check out
some shiny contests
but I still think that that's a decent
dashboard
and everyone in this room can build this
dashboard
without writing our code
without prior knowledge of shiny and you
can do it in two minutes and 22 seconds
I know but I can prove it to you
I have a video and you can see the timer
on the bottom right
so if you open up the dashboard Builder
you created with a blank screen and if
you want to visualize data well you need
data so I downloaded some of my chess
games saved it as a CSV file
and then I'm just logging it into the
dashboard Builder
and then I can add add elements like a
table about the date and the results of
my game and then I'm adding a graph
about my rating points so in chess if
you win games you gain rating points if
you lose you lose rating points so you
can visualize this I can add some value
boxes about the number of games I've
played the number is too high and my
Peak rating
and then I can add more elements and if
it's too small for you if you can't see
everything that's going on that's fine I
just wanted you to take away how easy it
is
you don't have to write any code and
trust me it's also a lot of fun
and while I'm here creating the last
couple of graphs the next part is to the
interesting part there's an export
button up there
and once you click on export the
dashboard will generate our code it
generates the r code that is needed to
build this dashboard
and then it downloads this and then you
can you you can open it up
in our studio
and then
you open up the file and once you hit
run
and now look it looks exactly that the
one we just created
okay so now you have a first impression
what the dashboard Builder can do so I
quickly want to say what it is not
so it's not a standalone tool it's not
power bi Tableau or whatever in r
why not I think these tools are great
but there are certain soft locks I think
with every tool
you have the ease of use versus the
extendability and power now this part is
highly opinionated so please don't be
angry I think power bi is easy to use
but it's not powerful you can't do
machine learning deep learning serious
data science or if you want to do it
it's very hard
and then look let's look at R if you
combine it with HTML JavaScript and CSS
it's super powerful we all know what R
can do but I would argue it's not that
easy to use so what can we do well we
can use R and shiny which is a bit
easier to use
but I still think there's something up
there
and I want to go up there
what's up there well I think the up
there is a wysiwyck dashboard buildup
wysiwick means what you see is what you
get so if you have our markdown that's
not wizzy Wick because you have to build
it so if you want to increase the size
of a picture in markdown you have to put
in with 50 with 70 and then you build it
and then you can see oh it's too small
so you have to get back to the code if
you compare this to PowerPoint which is
wysiwyg if you want to increase the size
of an image you click on the image and
you scale it and then that's how big it
is that's what you get what you see is
what you get
but I also want all the power and
packages of r i want the data science I
want the machine learning I want the
visualizations
so
that's what I want a combination of
these
so why
what does it add who is it for and I
think there are two target groups the
first one beginners I don't think that
only data scientists should create
dashboards there are other Sciences they
have so much data so much Insight that
they can use to create dashboards but it
has to be easy to use because most of
them don't know how to write code and I
think the blank screen when you start a
project that's really frightening so if
we can help them first step without them
having to know how to program I think
that's going to lower the entry barrier
to data visualization
and then they're the experts but if you
just go to a client discuss how the
dashboard will look like that's never
going to be how it will look like in the
end so you
build the dashboard then you bring it to
the client it tells you oh can we change
this so you have to go back change it go
to the client can we change this no I
want you to be there in the room with a
client or maybe just with your team and
build a rapid prototyping build the
dashboard
so we're gonna streamline the dashboard
building process so you have more time
with the really interesting stuff
so now you're wondering how does that
work
if you open it up there are three
buttons and these three buttons are the
three steps you have to take you have to
import data then you can build the
dashboard and then you export it and
then there's the fourth open-ended step
improve and extend
so
we're gonna import data
we have this
module up here we can import data from
our our environment we can load external
files and Google Sheets now I did not
create this I shamelessly stole it from
the guys from dreamers dreamers yeah
and once you've loaded the data you can
start to build the dashboard
now there are two steps first you create
the element right now we support text
boxes value boxes data tables and graphs
so for text boxes boxes just put in the
text you want to be displayed
for Value boxes put in a title the value
and then an icon
data table also very easy just select
the columns you want to be displayed
but how are we gonna create GT plots
graphs without writing code
and thankfully the guys from dreamers
have this awesome skis package I'm sure
most of you have seen it
you see up there
in the top those are all your columns
from your data and then you can drag and
drop these columns and to the X the Y
maybe the color
whatever and then it's going to create a
graph for you
and then you have this element
and then you can
edit the content
you can scale it you can move it around
and you can also delete it
and then you're just going to repeat
these two steps so add an element
scale it add an element scale it add
more elements move them around
and then you'd kind of build your
dashboard
and as soon as you're happy with how it
looks
export it and when you export it you get
three files you have the r project
you get the data that you loaded in as
in dot RDS file and you get the app.r
file and in the app there's always a UI
and a server
and now let's look a bit deeper into the
UI and the server files let's start with
the UI for these two elements two value
boxes internally we use the grid stacker
package so we just add a gritsick item
give it a height a width x y give it
some ID some styling and then in there
please give us a value box output
now we're going to do the same for the
second one and if this looks a bit
complicated if it was too fast don't
worry all of this is 100 generated by
the Dashboard Builder and we also have
the same full server
we're going to render a value box which
value box well just for this title It
games played the value is 200 and then
we have an icon and a width and the same
for the second one and again 100
generated
but
now comes to the part where I have to
admit that I lied to you you do have to
write a tiny bit of code because look
the value boxes the values are hard
coded so if the data changes these
values will stay the same
and that brings us to the fourth and
final step to improve and extend now
that you have your dashboard
you can do so much with it and in our
case let's see okay games played
that's just the number of rows of my
data table
and the highest rating well the highest
rating is just the max of my rating so
you have to write these two tiny lines
of code and I think most of us most of
you all of you all of you can do that
and then when you've done that
you get your dashboard
now I know what you all want to do you
want to use the dashboard Builder it's
still in Alpha but it works
so you can get a demo on shinyapps you
can go to my GitHub that will bring you
to my GitHub
but
you need for both for the GitHub if you
want to run it locally and if you want
to run the apps that you created you
need the grid Circle package and you can
download this from GitHub I'm gonna put
it on Quran but right now you still have
to do the devtools install GitHub
and then how can we all improve the
dashboard Builder well I was a bit busy
the last two months because I had to
finish my Master's thesis but now
I've some free time I'm just job hunting
and I want to improve the dashboard
Builder so please if you have feedback
if you have ideas if you have questions
write me an email open up an issue on
GitHub or just ask me right now thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]